uh hi everyone I'm Noah Fleming I'm now
at Memorial University and I'm going to
be talking to you about this new paper
uh with Sam busser and wrestling paliato
uh titled the tfmp characterizations of
proof systems and monotone circuits
um so as the name suggests this paper is
going to talk about two Notions of
complexity uh first is uh uh circuit
complexity and in particular monotone
complexity and the second is proof
complexity so I'll start by introducing
both of these
um so we monitor the circuit complexity
um we're interested in certain models of
monotone circuits or monotone
computation
[Music]
um
we have some particular monotone
function in mind that we're interested
in the complexity of computing it and we
want to understand what the smallest
circuit in this model of monotone
computation is uh that computes this
function so we're interested in putting
lower bounds on
M circuit complexity of these functions
at
on the other hand proof complexity
studies
um the complexity of proving uh
tautologies so we have a particular
proof system in mind
um
and we're interested in the complexity
of proving subtitology F in this curve
system so what's the smallest proof in
this proof system of mystatology
um and so these are both very vibrant
areas of research
um and recently there's been kind of a
ton of breakthroughs that in both areas
that have resulted from uh uncovering
these surprising and very deep
connections between them
so on one hand we have interpolation
theorems
um which for certain proof systems term
proofs in those proof systems into
circuits in an Associated model of
monotone computation uh for computing
some Associated function
uh on the in the other direction we have
these query to communication lifting
theorems uh that turn uh computations in
some circuit model into proof Simmons
Associated proof system
um and these have been like really
really impactful recently
um they've resulted in a vast variety of
uh new lower bounds both the improved
complexity and monotone circuit
complexity and a bunch of surrounding
areas such as communication complexity
and extended formulations and so on
um and and really the reason why this is
happening is because this is allowing us
to use tools from a seemingly very
different area uh to be applied to the
areas we're looking at
um
and so this is giving kind of A New
Perspective which has been very useful
um
okay so these interpolation theorems and
query to communication lifting theorems
uh are very very good to establish very
useful
um and so a very natural question is
when can we expect a proof system or a
monotone circuit model to admit such an
interpolation theorem or lifting theorem
when uh for a given proof system how can
we tell if
we can take its proofs and turn it into
circuits or for a given circuit model
can we take its circuits and turn it
into proofs
um so that's the question that this
paper uh makes progress towards
answering
okay and to do so we use tools from the
world of tfnp so tfnp studies uh the
complexity of computing uh total search
problems or in particular efficiently
verifiable total search problems
um so recently the reason we use this is
that recently tfmp has kind of emerged
as this uh very cool road map uh for the
existence of interpolation escalation
theorems
um so I'll try to explain
how this came about
um
uh and to do so I'll I'm gonna first
talk about how both proof systems and uh
monophone circuit models can be
characterized by the complexity of
computing Associated total search
problems remember tfmp is the study of
total search problems
um So for anybody who's familiar with
creative communication lifting theorems
you might think that this picture that I
had up before
um is a little bit weird right usually
queried communication lifting theorems
uh lift a lower bounds on query models
to amounts of communication models not
prove systems to monitoring circuits and
um
so this is uh
um
this can kind of be thought uh of proof
as proof to Circuit in all of the cases
where we have these lifting theorems
um and this is because well on one hand
uh it's well known that many models of
monotone circuit complexity are
characterized by the complexity of
computing a total search Problem the
karsh mervickerson search problem in a
model of communication complexity
so you know this this equivalence here
is saying that
um for some models of modern circuit
complexity
um
their circuits are equivalent to
protocols in a model of communication
complexity for computing the monotone
carcamer Victors and search problem this
is the uh kind of an extension of the
um seminal result by karsh
and on the other hand
um
or proof complexity there is a total
search problem just like the monotone
customer Victorian game that
characterizes the complexity of proofs
in many proof systems this is known as
the false clause search problem
um very quickly it's not going to be
really relevant to this talk uh very
quickly the false class search problem
is you're given a tautology and a truth
assignment and you want to find a clause
that's falsified in the negation of that
tautology
um okay so we can actually view these
interpolation theorems and these
creative communication lifting theorems
as relating protocols query protocols
for the false clause search problem to
communication protocols for the monotone
Karcher pictures and search problem
these are both two total search problems
okay and so tfnp is the study of
computing total search problems or in
particular efficiently verifiable total
search problems it's total functional NP
um and so tfnb itself
um you can think of it as a as a
complexity class it doesn't it's very
unlikely to have uh complete problems
and so researchers focused on a number
of
interesting subclasses that do have
complete problems and so they've
organized these total search problems
into a variety of subclasses so here at
the top we have the class tfnp of
efficiently verifiable total search
problems at the bottom we have
functional P which is all the total
search problems that can be computed in
polynomial time and in between we have a
variety of classes Each of which has a
complete problem
okay and so in tfmp we typically study
the turing machine complexity of pillow
search from this just the functional
analog of NP however just like
um NP we don't we don't really have a
chance right now of of separating
um various uh tfnp classes like any
separation between tfmp classes would
apply P naught equal NP
um and so therefore it's been kind of
useful in order to get a understanding
of the lay of the land in order to
consider other models of computation a
place turing machine with something else
and so the classic standard model
computation instead to use is it's query
complexity or your decision tree
complexity
um and this started in this paper by
Beam at all
um who showed that you know separations
um in this decision tree model of pfmp
imply Black Box separations or generic
Oracle separations so
of being able to prove separations in
this decision tree model implies Oracle
separations between the tfmp classes and
gives us some sort of understanding of
the uh hopefully understanding the lay
of the land of of these tfmp classes
and where this interpolation theorems
and
um querative communication lifting
theorem stuff comes in
um really uh either started or became
like very clear in this early or this
fairly recent paper of goose kamath
Robert and sokolov
um who showed that certain proof systems
are actually equivalent to these uh
decision Treaty of MP classes
um
so in this case we're going to say that
these proof systems are characterized by
the tfmp class if they're equivalent and
what I mean by equivalent is I mean that
um every a total search problem in one
of these classes corresponds to a
um tautology that this proof system can
efficiently prayer
and so the first one uh was that the
class PLS is equivalent to resolution
and since then there has been quite a
number of
um
of equivalences
um
so similarly we can study instead of
using the model of computation which is
decision trees we can use communication
protocols
um and in the same paper uh Goose come
off forbearance sokolov showed that also
um certain certain monotone circuit
models are equivalent to these
communication tfnp classes
for example PLS is equivalent to
monotone circuits and yeah there's
there's a bunch of other things
okay
[Music]
um
so
the real upshot comes from the following
observation
um so when we have both a decision tree
characterization and a communication
characterization of the same tfnb class
so for example here we have PLS
um in the decision Tree World is
equivalent to resolution and PLS in this
communication world is equivalent to
monotone circuits then we immediately in
a black box way we get an interpolation
theorem
um and as follows just because
communication protocols can simulate
decision trees basically if if you look
at it this is really the only
observation you need
okay so it's a plot these
characterizations give us a black box
way to generate interpolation theorems
so here's the first interpolation
theorem from resolution of monotone
circuits like hijack and here's a bunch
of other ones and in fact
um you can essentially fit all of the
known interpolation theorems into this
model you may need to change the
definition of communication protocol to
be a different model but maybe this is
outside of stock
okay and the second observation goes in
the other direction
um you can view all of the known uh
query to communication living theorems
um as relating the communication version
of a tfmb class to its decision tree
version
so for example
um at the very bottom here we have the
famous Roz McKenzie
um holistic theorem
um which uh lifts lower bounds on
decision trees to lower bounds and
communication complexity or
this can be thought of instead as a way
to connect the communication version of
FP to the decision treated version of
that theme
and here are the other uh
many of the other main creative
communication looking cups
okay so here are our main two
observations and kind of the upshot of
these is that we can use this now use
this landscape of tfmp in order to
understand when interpolation and query
to communication lifting theorems occur
by understanding when proof systems and
monotone circuit models admit tfmp
characterizations
so now we can actually get necessary and
sufficient conditions for
um lifting theorems and interpolation
theorems
so this raises yeah two very natural
questions so under what conditions does
a tfmp class admit a proof system or
circuit characterization and the
converse under what conditions is a
proof system or circuit model uh admit a
tfnp characterization
and so
um the work of this paper answers both
of these we provide necessary and
sufficient conditions for each of these
okay so let's start with the first one
and I'll describe our results first for
proof complexity and then I'll talk
about the circuit complexity ones that
are very very similar
um
okay so under what conditions does a
tfmp class admit a perfect system
characterization
um so we showed that that every tfmb
class has a proof system which
characterizes it and
um if you think for a little bit it's
not too hard to come up with what this
proof system is it's it's kind of dumb
it is a proof system in the formal sense
but not a very natural one so proofs in
this proof system are just reductions to
a complete problem for this tfmp class
and you can see that this is a proof
system in the formal cookware kind of
sense
um and for the other direction maybe
this one's a little bit more interesting
um what conditions uh does proof system
have to satisfy in order to admit a tfnb
characterization so here we show that
um this is the case if and only if the
proof system p
um is well behaved in a certain formal
sense it's not super important we just
want it to be closed under decision tree
reductions
um and it has short proofs of its own
sounds so we can prove that
P proofs are sound so
more formally what we mean by proving
its own soundness we mean that it can
prove an efficiently verifiable version
of a reflection principle about itself
so efficiently verifiable
um is required by the pfnp world we want
to be able to check Solutions
efficiently
um
and a reflection principle this is
something that has been studied for a
while in complexity is a statement that
says that if F has a p proof then f is a
tautology you see write this down and by
efficiently verifiable we're going to
enforce that it's written down as a CNF
formula of poly logarithmic width
okay so a proof system admits a tfmp
characterization
um if and only if it has short proofs of
an efficiently verifiable uh reflection
principle about itself
and uh we also show that the uh this
proof system that we constructed from
ndtfmb class can create a reflection
principle of that
okay
um and as a proof of concept we give a
tfmb class that characterizes the
polynomial calculus this is kind of a uh
for those of you who are familiar with
tfmp this is a very natural sort of
dag-like version of PPA or ppad
depending on the field over which on
what calculus is defined and we show
that the polynomial calculus can prove
one of these efficiently verifiable
reflection principles about itself
okay
um so now let's move on to the
complexity versions of our results
um so we have the same questions you
know when does a tfmd class admit a
circuit characterization
um and we showed that every tfmb class
gets a uh has a model of monotone
circuit which characterizes it and it's
it's a similar one to the proof system
world
um
and also
um the other direction uh what under
what conditions does a monotone Circle
circuit admit a tfmp characterization
um so here we show that this is the case
if and only if the monotone circuit has
a universal family functions and is also
well behaved in the sense that it's it's
closed under uh low death reductions
um so what's a universal family of
functions
so it's a function f such that for any
partial function G if they're
um if there's a small circuit for G in
this monoton circuit model then there is
a strings ad such that if you set some
of the bits of f according to this
string set then
um f restricted by Zed is basically
equal to the partial function G
um so basically we can recover uh these
partial functions G
um
that uh C efficiently computes uh just
by taking F and restricted and the
second one is that c efficiently
computes this function f
so basically we can just focus on this
Universal family
okay
um so yeah to recap so we show that
um
if you have a monotone circuit model
then it admits a tsmp characterization
uh if and only if it has a universal
family assumption
okay so those are our main results I'm
not going to go into any more detail
beyond what I've just said
um look at the paper for that
um and I just want to end with one uh
very tantalizing I think open problem
which is so
um
by establishing
both proof and circuit characterizations
in the tfme class we immediately get a
lifting theorem or sorry immediately get
an interpolation Theory is the same true
for lifting theorems uh so if we have a
circuit and proof system
characterization of a tfnd class do we
immediately get a lifting theorem this
seems much more difficult to establish
than the
um
interpolation theorem Direction because
that one's just immediate but I think
this is a very exciting open problem
all right uh thanks for coming to my
talk